bonjour à tous bienvenue au salon de
l'agriculture de paris porte de
versailles très heureux de vous
retrouver pour ce numéro exceptionnel de
dimanche en politique sur france 3
bourgogne franche comté
nos agriculteurs peuvent-ils se passer
des pesticides et notamment du
glyphosate l'herbicide le plus
controversé l'assemblée nationale vous
le savez a refusé d'inscrire dans la loi
l'arrêt total de son emploi d'ici 2021
emmanuel macron a explicité sa vision au
début de ce salon mais des voix
s'élèvent pour demander son interdiction
totale rapide au nom du principe de
précaution
on en parle tout de suite dans dimanche
en politique
[Musique]
alors le monde de l'après pesticides est
il vraiment engager l'agriculture
française peut-elle prendre le chemin de
cette transition révolutionnaire qui
aujourd'hui il peut aider nos
agriculteurs à vivre cette transition et
se passer des produits phytosanitaires
un monde sans pesticide est il pour
demain on se questionne et on en débat
avec nos invités ici au salon de
l'agriculture de paris christian morel
bonjour vous êtes agriculteur à saône
dans le doubs membres de la fdsea du
doubs merci d'être avec nous je vous
aura tous nicolas giraud bonjour vous
êtes loueur à salins les bains dans le
jura secrétaire national de la
confédération paysanne
didier martin bonjour bon je vous êtes
député la république en marche de
côte-d'or rapporteur de la mission
d'information parlementaire sur les
produits phytopharmaceutiques frédéric
ruhr bonjour bonjour vous êtes dirigeant
et fondateur de géo chambre une start up
basée dans l'yonne qui propose des
alternatives naturelles aux pesticides
on évoquera c'est ses possibilités avec
vous dans quelques instants
merci à tous d'avoir accepté cette
invitation vous qui nous regarde et vous
pouvez bien sûr commenter cette émission
avec le hashtag dit mme paul bfc comme
dimanche en politique bourgogne franche
comté alors christian morel j'ai envie
de vous poser la question très
simplement et même un peu cash on va y
aller directement les pesticides le
glyphosate pour vous agriculteurs c'est
quoi c'est votre meilleur ennemi le
sparadrap dont vous aimeriez vous
débarrasser
quelque chose qui est indispensable pour
votre métier comment vous définiriez les
choses de réponse complexe quand même
dans un monde contexte quoique
l'agriculture a toujours fait que de
répondre à la demande du consommateur
depuis depuis très longtemps je crois
que nous avons toujours répondu alors
que seulement 4 quantitative ou
qualitative à ce que voulait le
consommateur aujourd'hui pesticides
pourquoi parce qu'à un moment donné
les plantes sont un peu comme nous on a
des jours de bien des jours où on est
moins bien un moment donné et parfois il
ya besoin aussi d'un petit renfort qui
s'appelle soit un fongicide soit un
pesticide à ce moment là vous dites
comme nous de vous comparer ça à des
antibiotiques par exemple en gros c'est
ce terme est un peu aussi complexe je
crois qu'il ya eu il ya eu beaucoup de
vedettes effort de fait par le monde
médical ces antibiotiques comme eu
beaucoup d'efforts de fait par le monde
agricole sur les pesticides à un moment
donné se croient que aujourd'hui ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que il ya déjà eu
cinq sens en matière active de supprimer
du marché la case ans donc c'est quand
même énorme
on l'a on est des produits de moins en
moins que lyon lyon encore c'est vrai
mais aujourd'hui pour se défaire de ça
il faudra quand même aller sur la
recherche et faire beaucoup de
recherches et avoir du temps devant nous
parce que c'est pas du jour au lendemain
c'est pas d'un claquement de doigts
qu'on va dire on arrête et pesticides du
jour au lendemain alors j'ai envie
d'entendre nicolas giraud tout de suite
parce que vous la confédération paysanne
vous êtes un peu plus
contre j'allais dire vous n'êtes pas
très favorable aux pesticides est ce que
vous avez l'impression que on peut s'en
passer et à quelle échéance nous fort ou
non franchement la conversation paysanne
ont fait le pari qu'on peut se passer
des pesticides ça c'est certain
après pour répondre à la première
question pour nous les pesticides il y a
deux problèmes il ya un problème de
santé et au départ spécialement pour les
paysannes et les paysans qui sont au
contact les 1er 2 des pesticides et pour
qui ça pose problème c'est la profession
c'est la profession agricole et la
profession qui a dans les dîners
dernières années le moins progressé en
espérance de vie donc on n'est pas
certain que soient les pesticides mais
en tout cas ça nous interroge
et la question qui se pose mais n'y a
aucune étude qui exceptionnellement
l'instant la créer et la deuxième chose
pour nous les pesticides cd des outils
de guerre économique qu'ont été mis en
place à un moment donné pour pourrait
nous expliquer qu'il fallait produire
moins cher qu'il fallait produire plus
et les paysans sont aujourd'hui
dépendant de ça et il va falloir les
aider pour ceux pour les ans passés
cette dépendance vous avez l'impression
d'être j'allais dire pesticides aux
dépendants vous aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
a cherché à produire un maximum un
maximum plus pour répondre à un besoin
des populations besoins des populations
à interne à la france besoins des
pelletées m'étais besoin d'exporter
aussi car on a on a aussi des marchés
extérieurs auxquels il faut qu'on met
que l'on réponde à un moment donné là
donc j'ai besoin de produire et c'est
vrai que la production c'est des emplois
tout au long de la chaîne donc c'est
vrai que on a peu besoin de ça mais moi
je fais je dis que demain ou dans dix
ans on va y arriver
on va arriver à passer le cap des
pesticides crois que comme on l'a
littéralement c'est c'est le sens de
l'histoire à mort et je crois qu'on le
voit il a tout le monde est d'accord sur
ce que vous vous dites dans dix ans on
va réussir à s'en passer
beaucoup disent en raison du milieu des
mesures de précaution nécessaires du
principe de précaution
il faut absolument s'en passer d'ici
trois ans qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez à ces trois ans a été dit sur
le glyphosate amende elle que le
président de la république a dit qu on
se passerait du glyphosate dans trois
ans alors que l'europe à 10,5 en hockey
mauricie
on va y arriver on va y arriver mais
attention on ira on a évolué à la
position des agriculteurs sur ce terrain
là ah oui mais même pendant ce salon de
l'agriculture on a vu que lé les choses
quand même évolué mais vous savez on est
on est aussi là pour produire et pour
répondre aux consommateurs
mais pour le consommateur de pesticides
je suis dit je suis agriculteur dans une
ronde dans une zone péri urbaine de mes
voisins sont mes consommateurs mais
consommateurs qui jouera envie d'être
empoisonné lorsque c'est le thème de
notre débat empoisonné par d'éventuels
pesticides et vous non plus vous avez
pas envie j'imagine moi non plus bien
entendu parce que comme m'a dit mme may
mais mon confrère jésuite revue
utilisateur a demandé donc c'est ma
santé qui est en jeu ici c'est pas envie
de jouer que ça non plus daviau dit qu
il ya des méthodes affaires et attention
parce que demain si on enlève par
exemple le glyphosate h on s'est
peut-être c'est du passage de tracteurs
supplémentaires qu'il faudra faire dans
cette même parcelle
je suis pas sûr que sur les gaz à effet
de serre on est aussi là il ya
certainement d'autres
il yad'autres ou pas ce que je pourrais
faire un sujet très sensible mais on
veut bien parler des gaz à effet de
serre un autre jour si vous voulez mais
on lira sur d'autres problématiques pour
pas que le mal soit l'ennemi du bien
attention didier martin on sait que dans
votre majorité ça a été compliqué vous
même vous avez évolué sur cette question
du glyphosate par exemple le président
la république on va l'entendre dans un
instant était au début du salon de
l'agriculture a inauguré ce salon en
disant on va y aller trois ans et c'est
finalement tout le monde est d'accord
pour dire faut y aller la question c'est
plutôt quand et comment quoi
voilà exactement donc il nous faut
trouver les solutions alternatives à
l'utilisation il faut bien le dire
de plus en raison de plus en plus
raisonnée mais encore très importante
des pesticides
c'est le sens du discours du président
de la république transformer notre
modèle agricole
c'est le sens aussi du discours du
ministre de l'agriculture qui veut
sortir les pratiques traditionnelles de
la dépendance aux pesticides
alors ça c'est j'allais dire c'est les
belles idées mais concrètement comment
ça pourrait se passer alors qu'après je
donnerai la parole à monsieur ruhr qui
lui a une à des solutions concrètes
concrètement on peut pas dire ça en une
minute
évidemment mais il faut prendre les
choses dans l'ordre c'est à dire
travailler filière par filière
territoire par territoire voir qui est
engagée dans cette conversion de la
grille
aux agricultures de l'agriculture
écologique et voir quels accompagnements
qu'elle recherche il faut conduire et
qu'elle soutient il faut apporter pour
aller vers cet excellent c'est cette
qualité est la solution pour la france
mais aussi pour l'europe parce que nous
sommes dans un contexte aujourd'hui
européens et nous ne pourrons pas tout
seul agir sens a entraîné avec nous nos
les autres états membres de l'union
européenne ne serait ce qu'à cause de
l'importation des produits y compris les
produits bio qui sont parfois douteux
quand ils viennent d'origine non
certifiées en fait des recours est-ce
que vous pouvez nous donner un délai sur
lesquelles on pourrait se passer des
pesticides et du glyphosate puisque vous
l'expérimenté déjà avec plusieurs
agriculteurs dans notre région ça ça
fait quatre ans que l'on développe des
innovations techniques des itinéraires
techniques qui sont dans les maraîchers
chez les en viticulture chez les
arboriculteurs ainsi que sur les
paysagistes on arrive à se passer de
glyphosate uniquement avait petite toile
de paillage de surfaces qui sont
nourricière on redécouvre les vertus des
fibres naturelles que nous on a un
procédé breveté sur l'europe et sa
fonction de ses deux usines
ces deux unités de culture tout à fait
ça marche pour tout type 2 est
aujourd'hui combien d'agriculteurs ont
adopté votre méthode par hectare au
moins 500 agriculteurs qui appliquent
leurs produits déjà à travers la france
et en europe
donc c'est évident que le l'agriculture
du vivant tout ce qui est économies un
peu plus certivéa la biodynamie etc sont
très attentifs à ces itinéraires
techniques la note a mis notamment en
vignes desquelles des terroirs un peu
pentue la problématique du glyphosate
deviennent très compliqué et les bio ne
peuvent plus appliquer donc il est
évident que les toile de paillage légère
et et faciles à transporter pour eux
c'est une vraie alternative
nicolas giraud je vous sent bouillir
depuis tout à l'heure parce que tout le
monde dit eh ben oui il faut sortir des
pesticides finalement finalement tout le
monde est d'accord avec vous tout le
monde est d'accord avec ça mais
j'entendais monsieur le député qu'il y
voit là dedans on l'a entendu dans les
discours des leds emmanuel macron
l'entente dans le discours de didier
guillaume 1 c'est très bien même
moi les discours on en a soupé et depuis
quelques années dans le monde agricole
moi je retiens juste un truc sur le
discours d' emmanuel macron c'est à un
an d'écart c'est sa venue l'année
dernière ici sur le salon où droit dans
ses bottes j'allais lire y répond un
jeune agriculteur qui lui explique que
ça va être compliqué de sortir du
glyphosate civic et c est lui répond je
ne veux pas être responsable pour les
générations futures donc nous on avait
une sacrée espérance d'avoir soit dans
la loi nous on pensait que ça pouvait
être inscrit à un moment donné dans la
loi et on a l'impression qu'aujourd'hui
on nous a parlé de trois ans la 10e par
le même besoin de le mettre dans la zone
dans la loi pour faire 3 gens et on nous
dit que quelques mois après qu'on pourra
pas faire 100% et yoyo il y en aura qui
pourront pas sortir
on a l'impression que très vite on fait
reculade sur reculade et et nous quelque
part ça nous fait un peu parce que c'est
il faut il faut prendre ce sujet à bras
le corps parce que on a besoin d'en
sortir juste un petit exemple on parlait
là il nous expliquait un petit peu les
alternatives qui peut y avoir
on est deux producteurs je crois en les
a comptés sur le lac ont t il faut
absolument on va sortir du glyphosate
sur les prairies nous on espère à la
conversation paysanne qu'on en sorte
aussi sur les céréales et que ce soit
aussi même un moyen de tirer avec nous
toute la bourgogne franche comté toute
la région proche de 20 elle est le vin
également mais mais mais la région
bourgogne franche comté qui fournit les
céréales pour nos troupeaux l'hiver
qu'on peut le pas forcément produire sur
nos sur nos territoires
si on arrive avec une filière qui marche
bien le comté qui rémunère ces paysans
qui a des marges de manoeuvre au niveau
économique
on peut arriver à tirer tout le monde
vers le haut et à ce moment là c'est un
peu un appel d'air pour avancer au
niveau économique vers une sortie des
pesticides propositions retenues alors
rien il ya des gens qui veulent réagir
en face de vous on va les faire réagir
dans un instant mais on va puisqu'on en
parle depuis tout à l'heure écouter le
président la république qui a réaffirmé
donc son idée au début du salon la fin
des pesticides d'ici trois ans sans
passer par la loi mais simplement avec
la volonté des acteurs de la filière et
le soutien de l'état c'était samedi
dernier ici au salon de l'agriculture je
propose d'écouter emmanuel macron nous
partions en fin d'année 2010 est
vers 10 ans de renouvellement
d'autorisation du glyphosate même quinze
ans au départ la france s'est mobilisée
nous nous sommes battus pour faire voter
au niveau européen cinq années est ce
que nous voulons faire nous c'est faire
mieux par an sur transposant c'est
l'engagement que j'ai pris donc pas en
passant dans la loi une contrainte qui
aurait créé une différence par rapport à
nos voisins mais en montrant dans les
faits que nous pouvons le faire en trois
ans par la mobilisation collective par
des solutions co-construite filière par
filière je pense très profondément que
nous pouvons y arriver
je pense d'ailleurs très profondément
que nous sommes en train d' enclencher
la dynamique qui nous permettra d'y
arriver
je veux y voir une opportunité par
exemple quand je regarde le vignoble
français
je pense que nous pouvons en faire le
premier vignoble du monde sans
glyphosate dans 80% des cas cette
transition va d'ailleurs s'effectuer
sous trois ans elle s'effectuera parce
qu'il ya des efforts de l'innovation de
la volonté de se mobiliser
voilà emmanuel macron c'était samedi
dernier au salon de l'agriculture lors
de l'ouverture de ce salon
christian morel la co-construction
filière par filière secteur par secteur
pour sortir dans trois ans j'espère que
vous avez déjà commencé à bosser parce
que ça paraît quand même l'échéance
paraît quand même très proche
yann entendu que notre coq mec mais
comment sort on a commencé à travailler
là dessus dans les chambres
d'agriculture dans l'est dans les
coopératives ne crois que il ya un réel
besoin si le gouvernement le dit on le
fera froch loi est claire alors il n'y a
pas de contrainte ya aucune obligation
vous avez entendu emmanuel macron il
compte sur vous les acteurs des
différentes filières agricoles pour
mettre en place sa il dit pas on va vous
obliger moi je passe je veux pas être
dogmatique d'être pragmatique dans
l'histoire tragique de l'histoire figure
a demandé comment qu'on fait quelle
solution alors on a quelles solutions on
a pour faire ça on va faire un moment
donné on va qu'est ce qu'on va faire on
le retourne et plus les sols l'eau va
retourner les sols attention on n'est
pas sûr que ça marche tous les coups on
va reprendre la charrue on le fera on
sait le faire
outré le faire et ça fait longtemps que
les buffets donc dans bien des secteurs
voulu à cause de l'érosion des sols à
par doumbia les bains et phénomène s'est
pas fait parce qu'on peut pas ou
attention on
vite ou pas faire un mal pour un bien
avant les dons après il n'y a pas que il
n'ya pas que diffuse à ta demande et on
en passe politique
il ya d'autres choses à voir audi et je
crois pouvoir l'ensemble que d'état leur
l'ensemble des filières l'ensemble des
rotations et un mot donné que trois
faire six mois j'ai travaillé aussi
proche du bio à monnet il faudra
peut-être qu'on arrête de faire des
rotations très simples comme on l'a fait
les orge colza un mort et qui sont des
demandeurs et faire amender amener
d'autres productions et pour d'autres
productions
il faut de l'investissement et là
j'attends aussi de le prix dont la
république en disant ok oliva mais on
nous aide à investir
on nous aide à changer de service
politique
on ne va pas le faire en claquant des
doigts c'est une sacrée balles de
ping-pong quand même j'entends le
président de la république qui dit
co-construction filière par filière et
donc finalement ce sont les acteurs qui
vont mettre en place ça et j'entends les
acteurs dire oui mais qui ce qui nous
aide et comment on va faire alors didier
martin oui mais il ya la loi et ya la
loi américaine eut finalement serait pas
par la loi - loi de finances pour aider
des agriculteurs en conversion
ça c'est une chose et ensuite il ya la
loi sur l'agriculture que nous venons de
voter qui interdit les rabais sur la
vente des produits pesticides qui sépare
le conseil des agriculteurs annuel est
en cours de campagne et pas d'un
attention vers la loi et l'interdiction
reste larmes suprême
si les filières dans les rendez vous de
son action c'est en travaillant main
dans la main avec les professions et
toutes les filières ne sont pas au
rendez vous magne la diminution des
pesticides
quantitativement également si on
n'arrive pas pour 85% à ceux des cas se
passer du glyphosate est bien là la loi
interviendra pour effectivement très
bien comme les négociations
l'assurance-chômage finalement au bout
d'un moment vous reprenez la main et
vous faites c'est drôle c'est le rôle de
l'état c'est le rôle de l'état de
reprendre quoi ne pas le faire tout de
suite alors mais c'est ce qu'on nous
sommes en train de faire les
négociations sont engagées
mais c'est vrai que dans les zones
défavorisées simples il est difficile de
se priver immédiatement de 0,5 litre de
glyphosate parents et moins dans mon
département la côte d'or est bien là où
on ne pouvait pas faire de culture
maintenant fait de la culture c'est de
la conservation des sols
il faut encore une utilisation
résiduelles pendant quelques années
frédéric roux
pour vous vous avez le sentiment que ces
agriculteurs qui veulent changer de
méthode
ils ont besoin d'être aidés vous qui les
accompagner dans cette transformation
dans cette transition
en fait dans le sud de lyon deux et
arriver à mettre en place une filière
complète
ça veut dire qu'on a des agriculteurs
qui commence à produire du chanvre sans
glyphosate ça absolument aucun intrant
on arrive à le transformer avec une
green tech une belle usine qui est toute
verte et on arrive à satisfaire des
maraîchers et de faire une économie
verte donc vous vêtir donné les
difficultés qui veut que weeds morel ça
veut dire qui en fait il faut donner un
coup de main à la filière complète et
que les gens puissent regarder ce qu'ils
achètent
à partir du moment où il ya une
traçabilité sur les produits et qu'on
regarde août comment ils sont faits et
de quoi ils sont composés
je pense que les gens viendront petit à
petit par des produits 100% naturels et
pas des fibres et porter quoi si vous
permettez vous permettez la mort parce
que le temps file
non mais c'est très important ce qui
vient d'être dire la filière chanvre
retrouve aujourd'hui un débouché
exceptionnel à la fois pour faire des
tissus des tice et en fibres naturelles
qui évite l'utilisation des herbicides
l'utilisation des herbicides est aussi
une entreprise de fontaine lès dijon qui
à partir du chanvre fait une sorte de
matière plastique beaucoup plus légères
écologique en fibres naturelles et ça
c'est des plastiques dans l'automobile
d'envoyer des bâtiments pour l'isolation
que soit l'automobile pour les
plastiques traditionnels leur
remplacement
la filière chanvre c'est très
intéressant nicolas giraud vouliez
réagir à tout ce qui se fait je voulais
je voulais réagir en expliquant que bien
entendu qu'on le fera pas en claquant
des doigts et bien entendu qu'on a
besoin des politiques de politique
publique forte et ambitieuse
est ce que pour vous il ya une volonté
politique aujourd'hui ben aujourd'hui on
n'en doute quelque peu parce que j'ai
dit on en avait l'occasion
dans la loi gré culture alimentation 1,2
mètre le glyphosate l'interdiction du
glyphosate dans la loi et 2 certains ont
essayé ça n'a pas marché c'est ça et
deux d'avancé plus fortement sur une
meilleure répartition de la valeur dans
les filières qui est le point important
comment voulez vous sortir des
pesticides dans les filières sans avoir
une meilleure répartition de filières et
des moyens économiques donner aux
paysans pour faire autrement
alors qu'est ce que vous appelez moyens
économiques est-à-dire d
des moyens économiques c'est du revenu
ceinture venue tout simplement les
subventions bien sûr que s'il ya aussi
le volet subventions les la politique
agricole européenne ces neuf milliards
d'euros qui tombent tous les ans sur
pour l'agriculture française est ce
qu'avec ses 9 milliards d'euros
on n'est pas capable de prendre à bras
le corps un débat aussi important que la
sortie des pesticides est ce qu'il a dit
pendant les négociations federico est-ce
qu'il faut l'inscrire dans les
négociations la réforme de la pac la
politique agricole commune
il est clairement actuellement je
reprends des chiffres le budget des
pesticides et des plastiques à
l'agriculture c'est 8 milliard d'euros
par an et on se rend compte que si la
pac la future pac n'intègre pas les sols
vivants n'intègre pas cette logique
d'agriculture durable avec des filières
nouvelles qui sont sans phyto en amont
etc
il y aura de réels problèmes si la pac
n'intègre pas ces questions morales tout
à fait je crois que ce concours est tous
d'accord sur un point etc si on veut
baisser et pesticides
il faut des outils économiques nouveau
on a une chance au niveau de la future
pac
on peut voulait il faut une coordination
européenne aux siens au voeu de caunes
régions européennes la france peut
passer à 12% de fléchage sur des suds de
son budget pac sur une transformation au
niveau des opérateurs économiques
allons-y allons-y il faut je crois qu'il
faudra mettre de l'argent sur des outils
nouveaux sur des filières nouvelles car
tout ce qu'on a aujourd'hui dans des
filières des anges colza qui ont gagné
le paysage la 30 ou 40 ans dans un
système sans pesticide ne passera pas il
faut la ramener autre chose
autre production le chanvre la luzerne
et autres choses dans notre paysage pour
y passer
hélas hélas vous dites ça va prendre du
temps l'inter prend du temps est de il
faut créer les outils économiques
on les a pas lésiné n'a pas aujourd'hui
et d'eric roy lé c'est vrai que les
outils industriels formeront le paysage
i comme routes de la manche jusqu'à
laval s'il n'a pas les outils
industriels qu'ils soient vertueux ça
sera de la délocalisation systématique
les 8 milliard d'euros que je disais
tout à l'heure comme des budgets qui
sont deux des plastiques des bio
plastiques et pesticides c'est de 100%
de l'importation alors que là on recrée
de la richesse pour les agriculteurs que
je sais payer sur un produit qui ne
valorise pas
alors pour vous didier martin la
prochaine étape là c'est quoi on entendu
le président arrive d'ailleurs parlé des
vignobles du vignoble français chez nous
en bourgogne franche comté c'est
important est ce que le vignoble par
exemple selon vous qui est député de
côte-d'or est prêt à franchir le pas est
déjà finalement sur les rails de la prée
pesticides alors moi je vais pas parler
à la place des viticulteurs mais en tant
que député de côte-d'or je dis banco
je crois que ce soit la côte d'or la
bourgogne où la franche comté le vin est
un produit extrêmement emblématique il
ya le lait bien entendu on en a eu deux
exemples sur la table avec du fromage et
d'avoir des vins de bourgogne et de
franche-comté qui serait effectivement
produit 100 leaf ozap
ce serait quand même à condition que le
consommateur le sache
à condition que la formation le
consommateur puisse choisir ses produits
en toute connaissance de cause parce
qu'il y aura quand même une valeur à
payer supplémentaires je crois
qu'aujourd'hui sur le glyphosate et
solutions existent alors c'est pas ça
résout pas tous les problèmes la
question du glyphosate
je suis d'accord la pac le verdissement
de la politique agricole commune et
celle théologie morale des agriculteurs
il doit être reconnu et rémunérés qui
dit marta cette différence qui va y
avoir finalement entre les trois ans
potentiel pour la france et les cinq ans
pour l'europe l'union européenne avant
l'interdiction du glyphosate
alors les trois en trois ans ou 5 ans
effectivement la décision que la france
veut prendre en sortir dans trois ans
dans une mission aura mais lire
l'argumentaire les députés vont suivre
le plan de sortie du glyphosate cinq ans
c'est la durée qui a été autorisé par
l'union européenne pour commercialiser
les produits contenant du glyphosate qui
va bien y avoir un décalage
il faudra apporter la preuve de notre
volonté et les éléments probants pour
sortir de cette autorisation nicolas
giraud plus question morale juste juste
une réaction
alors quand je vous entends dire qu' il
va falloir que le
qu'on communique dessus elle
consommateurs sont prêts à payer plus
cher globalement à mon avis - le
consommateur et paiera pas plus cher
après il faudra lui faire comprendre
mais globalement il paiera pas plus cher
quand on a une agriculture qui donne une
direction intensive qui donne une
direction où on a des problèmes de santé
publique où on a les problèmes de
pollution de l'eau de pollution des sols
on a une alimentation qui est pas
forcément de qualité par rapport à aux
attentes du consommateur
eh ben ça engendre tout des coûts tout
les externalités négatives qui coûtent
pas au consommateur quand il achète son
vin ou son produit mais qui coûte à la
société de manière générale bien sûr il
nous et nous ils nous sont qu' il faut
qu'on aille vers l'intérêt général
plutôt qu'une somme d'intérêts
particuliers qu'ils soient économiques
ou financiers et ça c'est le rôle des
politiques publiques questions morales
voulait simplement répondre à ça qui est
que un jour dans l'important c'est the
economist a dit à très peu de temps que
la france aujourd'hui avec l'agriculture
la plus durable est la plus à l'est
on l'a entendu vous pouvez pas dire le
contraire vous pouvez pas dire le
contraire
il y anime le géoïde et la mieux
organisée amorim est tout répond à tous
ces nouveaux défis répondre au défi du
seul défaut date pour répondre aux défis
de demain qu'on aura les sans pesticides
la france sera obligée de monter en
gamme
on va monter en gamme de notre
production parce qu'on a d'autres pays
opérant d'autres pays européens d'autres
pays mondiaux compris dans le cas
certains marchés donc notre objectif
c'est de monter en gamme de produire
mieux nous produire des produits plus
élaborés ou rester de mise sur le marché
amm n'est dupe aussi pas trop trop plus
cher jour le constructeur ce qu'il faut
pas juste une petite réaction
évidemment oui c'est vrai que
l'agriculture française est remarquable
mais un an
en même temps votre syndicat la fnsea
donne une direction au monde agricole
sur une volonté d'intensifier une
volonté de produire plus vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure et une volonté quelque
part d'industrialiser le modèle et à
partir du moment où on donne cette
direction là nous on soulève le risque
que ça fait peser sur un la disparition
des paysans
2 les problèmes territoriaux les
problèmes environnementaux une un
exemple tout bête qu'est poêlé avec les
pesticides mais si on veut si on estime
que notre agriculture est la meilleure
du monde
à ce compte là on aurait dû être les
trois syndicats les quatre syndicats
agricoles ensemble ray
quand la confédération paysanne a
démonté la salle de traite des
millevaches pour expliquer que c'était
pas le modèle qu'on voulait partir vous
n'avez pas l'impression nicolas giraud
que les tout le monde on revient un peu
sur sur vos positions quand même il ya
il ya encore ne serait ce qu un an on
était loin de cette évolution est ce que
ça vous fait pas quand même plaisir
abbas quelles quelque part que nos connu
au mot soit repris et puis qu'on nous
explique qu'il va falloir faire une
transition agricole que dans la bouche
des responsables agricoles fnsea on
entend de ça j'ai bien bouge dans les
landes la république on entend de ça
c'est très bien bien bien déçus de noël
et les consciences change marc après
comme je disais tout à l'heure
maintenant on attend des actes parce que
c'est ça urge ça urge pour les paysans
ça urge pour les consommateurs et
surtout il peut y avoir des points
d'accord quand même on est pour un
avenir sans pesticides on est on n'est
pas si loin que ça c'est beaucoup de
territoires aux dérision ou aux
dirigeants de l'agriculture et les uns à
côté des autres on arrive à le faire
on arrive à le faire mais à un moment
donné faut être jeudi climatique
d'affaires de millevaches
ok on va pas revenir là dessus à mandri
parce que c'est quand même c'est quand
même on va on refera un débat promis on
viendra conter par bercy d'avoir
d'autres y voient là dessus et on
remercie
merci à tous merci aux équipes
techniques de france télévisions pour la
réalisation de cette émission ici au
salon de l'agriculture de paris dans un
instant le point sur l'actualité
régionale
et puis dimanche en politique la suite
avec francis letellier
bon dimanche à tous sur france 3
[Musique]